hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play slender
the arrival okay
i made a huge mistake and a huge waste
of time
by actually going and going through this
for about three hours
all recording while so taking up
hundreds of gigabytes and frat files and
doing this without realizing that i
didn't update my game so i finally
updated to 1.2 so let's hope
that this works because i don't know if
it will i've been doing this over and
over i've been doing every permutation
every combination every possible thought
into making this work and it did not so
i am at the end of my rope if it doesn't
work um i'm going to give this three
attempts if it doesn't work
then i give up i am done
i am done son i i'm oh man so let's just
get down there as fast as possible i
don't have time to waste i don't have
time to do anything
i just i don't even have time to take in
the essence of the environment around me
i can smell the no no time dust reel the
trees
okay all right
let's just get down there get in okay oh
by the way
if you guys don't know what i'm rambling
about
um i'm trying to find the easter egg
there's a secret level
um in this somewhere where if you go in
the house you can see over there there's
a poster on that wall there so what you
need to do
is you need to go into the house and get
the flashlight and turn on the radio and
that's it some people say you need to
touch that so i'm gonna touch that
but ah here's the flashlight right away
but the basic principle that i saw is
that they were lolly gagging around in
the house
doing absolutely nothing so let's just
lollygag a bit
man
i've been listening to those songs over
and over again oh it's slendy hey slandy
you're an a-hole you're an ass
i've been yelling at him every single
time i see him when i did this before on
on the third try
i thought i had it i swore that i had it
because he appeared right here but i've
eventually realized he learned he
appears all over the place
okay
and then we sprint towards the poster we
split towards the pasture
i should keep an eye out
oh my god
something happened
you do not know how much that means to
me
okay
all right okay
oh god i'm so i'm so happy right now
something actually happened i can't
believe it oh my god this is like the
greatest moment of my life even though
you guys don't understand you don't know
how hard i've been trying to get
something to happen and how stupid i
feel for not updating my game that's on
me that's on me but this oh
god
[Music]
it's finally happening
oh man
i've been waiting
and waiting and trying
and trying
over and over and over and over and over
and over and over again
now i just need to do it two more times
and then we'll get sorry i got something
on my finger that's a blood blister
don't worry about that it's a big old
freckle no
no drawing your happy little thing i'm i
know
what the
i kept getting like pushed to the side i
don't know why
slendy are you pushing me with one of
your tentacles ha ha oh oh it tickles
hahaha
okay i'm pretty i'm pretty much drained
of all my funny juice i am
i have nothing entertaining to say
throughout this entire video because
i've been
talking to myself for three hours
straight
throughout the day today when absolutely
nothing was happening so i've got
nothing funny to say
at all
nothing not a thing
[Music]
what nice music
where dare bill you
hey slendy you're a dick
you're a dick hey
he keeps running away he's such an
a-hole
and don't be fooled by that i've seen
that before and nothing's going to
happen okay
come on you drag
wait
oh come on
wait no i gotta do it one more time and
then i'll be done
wait
oh
oh my god i did it i finally did it i
finally did it oh my god that is so
weird though
oh my god oh my god i finally did it
ding fing
oh man i finally did it i'm gonna go
play on the other swing set screw all
the through the house i'm going on the
other side i'm gonna slide down the
slide
in this bizarro world
what the hell is happening here
my word
i don't care
okay
[Applause]
okay all right enough horsing around
let's um
[Music]
let's do something here
don't like that sound in the background
but whatever
hello
anybody
oh okay i'll turn on the radio
[Music]
all right i guess i'm in the house now
that's weird i seem to have gained
teleportation patterns powers
[Music]
hey door come on
i guess it wants me to find the key
hi i wanted to go in there hold on hold
on
hey
stop it i'm going in there you can't
stop me
hey
you son of a monkey
somehow that music makes this all seem a
little bit weirder
i'm gonna
hang on
well that seems relatively normal
oh my goodness open door
jeez the doors are not behaving
correctly whoa oh
it's a perfectly normal potted plant
nothing strange about that
turn that off
no thank you
i'm in a rum i'm in kate's room okay
this is where i wanted to go okay so the
window is broken so this is after thrown
out
what is that
what is that a picture of some creek i
think
stop it now okay
oh i got a note what did i get
why can't i read it i'll read it later
once i get to the menu i got a note
i got a note in the ah
can i leave now
i would like to
i got the note can i leave now
hey
okay that's weird
wait a minute
are you out there you a hole
lock
[Music]
charlie mathison what the hell
can't back out am i really back out
wait a minute what was
i'm lost can you find me
i'm not out am i
what was that page i got
what did i get i'm back here now
[Music]
i'm lost can you find me i'm trying
trying to find you i got
okay we're starting right
i like you i want to play a game are you
kidding me i do not
i will find you
oh screw you charlie matheson
is this some is this oh my goodness it's
dark out
is this like another proxy like uh
now
i'm like somehow his psychedelic powers
oh
got the page
i got that page already didn't i
oh the point
what was the point
[Music]
what am i looking for
open the damn doors jesus
ah
oh come on door damn it
[Music]
what am i looking for
come on
jesus balls door
what am i looking for what am i looking
for am i looking for a key or what or
what
or what
oh this is so weird
[Music]
you found me good for you
congratulations
ah
oh [__]
everything's on fire
oh this is good
well um
i can't move
there's the window
what's the dealio
hey
slandy what wait a minute
wait hey
hey you're back up
you back up
all right
hey
oh no
i am dead
i am dead apparently
what the hell
i'm dead okay i am
i'm officially dead there's nothing else
right there's nothing else to that
i am dead i
i guess that's it all right then
so uh
yeah
about that what the hell
all right
i got no idea but i finally found it oh
my god after three hours i was i don't
know if that was worth it but that was
ah
i'm getting out of here so if i needed
to do something else there let me know
but i'm pretty sure that's it so
thank you all so much for watching click
the annotation for more videos it i've
done and as always i will see you
in the next video
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah i found it